kyle you're on the air howard i love the
music talk lately
so i gotta ask you who are the top three
greatest rock bands
of all time whenever you say what are
the top three
rock bands rock now if you're talking
overall singular artist i can talk to
you about james brown i could talk to
you about a lot of different people who
were important
and [ __ ] all that [ __ ] with buddy
holly and the crickets and all that crap
none of it mattered till the beatles
[ __ ] elvis [ __ ] crickets
all that [ __ ] crickets
i tell you the beatles number one
band of all time sergeant pepper's
magical mystery tour
forget all those albums if they had only
put out rubber soul
if they'd only put out help you would
have said
oh my god that was the greatest band
ever if you want to sit and argue it
you're a mutant
you don't even know what you're talking
about it's always the beatles in any
discussion so already
kyle we've eliminated one of the slots
so you really ask me who are the two
greatest
bands of all time they only released 10
albums i think so
they weren't around that long really so
their
impact was greatly limited kyle how old
are you
uh 26. okay so they're impacting
i can't even tell you their impact
musically i think that there are
better bands idiot all right so who's
better okay i would say led zeppelin
queen i would say rush all right that's
a dopey list
but you're a 26 year old kid who knows
nothing what do you do for a living
i'm a music teacher oh this is a shame
[Laughter]
in illinois these kids they're steered
the wrong way
they're being steered the wrong way the
music teacher thinks russia is the
greatest band of all time
you brought up queen queen you know we
all love queen you saw the movie kyle
and now you're all charged up
if you knew your rock history you know
that brian may has frequently sighted
the beatles as an inspiration for queen
and of course it is
everybody has to cite them so you've got
the beatles
and then the second group without a
doubt no argument
the rolling stones why because the
rolling stones did something
so unique they built off of a blues
foundation
and they created masterpieces i can't
ever really tell you the rolling stone
because i
don't really get their music what is
there to understand my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm going gonna tell you and i don't
mean this with disrespect
maybe you should think about becoming an
accountant not a musical or a gym
teacher i don't know
gym teacher you should teach the gym
class
coming at you wnbc jumping jack flash
the rolling stones
gives me the chills do you have the
chills kyle
howard i understand that i said do you
have the chills i just asked the
question do you have the chill
yes i do have the children all right
that's what you want what about
i can't get no satisfaction brilliant
all of them you know brilliant and now
we get to number three
led zeppelin is the number three
greatest band of all time again because
of when they came about
the body of music these riffs that jimmy
page came up with john bonzo bonham on
drums
and robert plant's vocals were insane
and you have to think of what happened
to music after this
that's right music changed did how many
women rejected me to this music
whenever this song comes on my balls
immediately turned blue
because i never got laid to any of this
music
have i answered your question kyle yes
howard i'm about to go teach now
i will use your wisdom john hein has
issues with my list
i'll preface by saying i agree with your
top three
beatles stone zeppelin however i am
highly offended by you and robin
constantly trashing rush
making them the punchline of all the
jokes this
gentleman calling in is a music teacher
so clearly he has some type of expertise
you know i never said this to you before
because i didn't want to insult you john
but i'm going to tell you something
okay what i know about you is this you
like
hamburgers with no toppings no
compliments
and that my friend is the equivalent of
rush a hamburger
with no toppings